what's going on guys this is rob uh if
you guys enjoy my content make sure you
hit the subscribe button
and make sure you hit that little bell
so you never miss out on my sexy voice
okay so we are getting into uh what's
probably at least what i would consider
to be one of the greatest x-men stories
ever told
this is god loves man kills we're doing
part one this is actually a graphic
novel 84 pages
split into four parts this story was
written back in 1983 and this is chris
claremont at his best
but there is going to be a moment in
this video this
might be a little controversial but that
was the nature of chris well there'll be
a couple moments really like when the
story opens up it's controversial but
but chris claremont saw the x-men as
like a soap opera as opposed to like a
traditional superhero team
and so he wrote them that way and so the
story the story reflects that so it's
this is this is classic chris claremont
right so the guys who are curious what
chris claremont's x-men was like back
during the 17 years he was writing it
this is exactly what it was like this i
think is like the penultimate x-men
story like the greatest x-men story ever
but what this does
is this opens up with a couple of kids
all right like a couple of young kids
and as they're running through
these kids mark and jill they're
basically fleeing for their lives and
it's pretty crazy because
we're not initially given an indication
all we really get is this thing where
jill asked about where their parents are
and mark's response is well don't worry
about them they can't help us anymore
and in the middle of them running
mark is suddenly shot from behind and
that's when you basically realize who's
chasing after them that it's a group
called the purifiers now the purifiers i
mean we're going to kind of suspend
our knowledge of like what the story is
so if you guys are familiar with this
and how it ends all that kind of stuff
do not spoil anything
please for the love of god do not spoil
anything but the purifiers are
pretty extreme which is exactly what
happens here and there's a reason why
claremont does this the statement of
these purifiers is you know like like
we're purifiers and if you don't know
what our mission is you should know by
now and so we end up finding out the
purifiers are the ones that killed their
parents
and then like chase that like these kids
just flee you know just just took off
for their lives as soon as you know
their parents had died like when
everything happened and that's the
nature of claremont writing right like
claremont wouldn't always go through and
give us like a beginning a middle and an
end to a story he would just pick up in
the middle of it and then just go
forward towards the end and it was cool
because what it did is it kind of left
your imagination to wonder what happened
beforehand
that led up to that and so we don't see
the parents of these kids killed
because the parents being killed is not
what's significant what's significant
is the heartless nature of the purifiers
when they say like we're gonna send you
to meet your parents the responsive mark
is you killed them and they're like yeah
and we're gonna kill you too and they
shoot him on the spot they kill him on
the spot
and then the little girl like jill
starts crying she's like why why are you
doing this and then she's executed and
the response to the purifiers is because
you have no right to live
this is callous i mean it's the most
heinous reason like the most heinous
thing that a person could do
not only that just to add icing on the
cake not only that this takes place in a
playground so the purifiers take the
bodies of the kids
string them up and leave them for the
world to see for like every young person
to see
and it's and it's it's so dark and it's
so
twisted and so screwed up but that was
the nature of chris claremont's x-men
chris claremont's x-men was designed to
tell the story of a persecuted group and
that was the reason why the x-men were
so impactful back then because it wasn't
like the x-men were just stand-ins for
african-americans there were stand-ins
for like any group that had ever been
persecuted that felt they'd been
persecuted and were legitimately
persecuted that's really what this was
about
and so instead of you know young people
finding these kids bodies strung up
instead after the purifiers make their
escape
magneto arrives and magneto's there and
and real you know witnesses what had
gone on or at least is aware that these
kids had been executed he wasn't
purviewed to like the entire goings-on
of the purifiers and what they had done
but for magneto this is crushing
this is absolutely devastating now this
is also kind of a big deal and the
reason why is because when it claimed
when it came to claremont if he wasn't
picking up stories in the middle of
everything he was setting the groundwork
for what would come later and so it was
not uncommon to see chris claremont
start a theme and then finish it like
five years later because he had like all
this time that's one of the reasons why
when claremont just abruptly left in
like 1992 that it was it was such a
huge blow to marvel because he had like
all these plot threads that had been
going on that all had to be wrapped up
in a matter in a matter of like six
months to a year
but with this theme here this takes
place about three years before uncanny
x-men number 200 and for those of you
guys who don't know what that means
that's the point where magneto takes
over leadership of the x-men and then
starts leading the new mutants and so
that was basically you know
chris claremont's way of revitalizing
his character and turning him into a
good guy but for magneto this is
devastating to him
because he has all this power right like
the power over magnetism like over the
electromagnetic spectrum he has all this
power he can shift the earth's poles
he can issue an emp like like a minute
an emp that'll take down power to the
planet there's all these things that he
could do
but despite all that power there's
nothing he could do to save these kids
there's nothing he could have done to
save their lives and so that's why it's
so crushing is because he's like always
one step behind them and so from here we
switch over to the striker building
striker worldwide as it's referred to
which is the head of william striker
himself and the striker crusade now this
is when his characters first introduced
and for those of you guys who don't know
william striker is a religious
fundamentalist he's he's
extreme here's the best way a really
good way to picture william striker
imagine the plot to handmaid's tale but
it's mutants instead of
women essentially but nonetheless he's
very religiously motivated and the
striker crusade is literally a crusade a
crusade against mutant khan but to up to
this point it's largely been pot shots
it's been shot on like a mutant here a
mutant there what striker's looking for
are big fish and he's looking for the
x-men and that's why he has
best his uh basically a secretary
grabbing like all these little these
little recording tapes these devices
that show what the x-men are capable of
they kind of highlight their powers and
what they're able to do
and then brings them all in for william
stryker to analyze because what he's
doing is essentially sitting down and
trying to plot a way to to take out the
x-men and so
it's it's interesting here because one
of the things that that he really talks
about at least one of the things just
kind of hit on is that in his mind
charles xavier is the go-to guy
charles xavier is the guy that needs to
be taken out he's the leader of the
x-men to take him down would be a
massive blow against the x-men roster
itself against like mutant kind as a
whole because he's such a public figure
now of course this also coincides with
him going to a debate
with charles xavier you know at the abc
studio so it's actually kind of a cool
little thing here but at this point we
switch over to
an encounter a really kind of a bar
fight basically between kitty pride and
a kid named danny now kitty pride facing
off against danny this is basically one
of those things that you didn't see
all the time but it was kind of a
coming-of-age scenario and the reason
why i say that is because
when kitty pride was introduced to
marvel comics and she was made part of
the x-men by chris claremont she was
very very very young she was somewhat
like 13 or 15 years old or something
along those lines but she was a young
girl who was coming into her own who was
basically
understanding what it meant to like grow
up and become a woman and different
things like that and that's why the
character of storm was brought in
as a kind of surrogate mother for for
kitty pride so she could basically raise
her teach her how to walk how to talk
how to conduct herself in a womanly way
and also walk her through a lot of the
experiences that women go through
as their bodies are beginning to grow
and as they're going through the whole
you know experience of
growing up and heartbreak and their
bodies are changing and so on and so
forth and so with all that happening
there's also another character here
named stevie hunter now with this whole
fight that breaks out it's kind of
interesting because it's obvious danny
had basically been been running off with
the mouth and we don't initially know
what had happened so you kind of have a
handful of people who are here in this
location at the same time right like you
have stevie hunter you have uh colossus
and they're watching the events unfold
now in this instance you basically have
colossus who kind of breaks up the fight
and you've got stevie hunter who comes
out and says what the heck is going on
here and that's what we end up finding
out that danny and his family
are part of the striker crusade and this
is actually a brilliant maneuver by
william striker if what he's looking to
do is launch a crusade against mutant
kind you do not do it yourself
you get everybody else in society to do
it for you if american people are good
at anything it's shunting blame to
someone else and say well it's not my
fault the news made me do it or like
jody foster told me to do it or
something like that but american people
are really good at like blaming others
and then just kind of absolving
themselves of responsibility and saying
well i mean you know i'm only human i
make mistakes and so that's one of the
reasons why it's such a genius move
because it's the nature of people to do
that get people get the average american
to criminalize mutants to demonize
mutants and then you've got a walking
talking army of some 200 million people
who are your army that are going to work
on your behalf to take down
a million mutants who exist in the
united states it's a genius maneuver but
this is also one of the more
controversial moments
because in the midst of all this stevie
basically tells kitty pride you have to
let it go
the guy's just saying things because
he's an well like you have to
let it just kind of roll off you and the
response of kitty pride is would you
take
the same the same stance if she called
you an n-bomb lover i'm not going to say
it but if she if she called you that
would you would you do that when this
happened when this was published i mean
i was two years old at the time i wasn't
reading comics when this when this when
i'm sorry i wasn't even born when this
came out but like looking back at like
the history of comics when this happened
when this was put into a comic book it
was huge
it was massive i mean it was it was like
you didn't do that
you didn't do this i mean in the history
in history publishing comics well
african americans may be depicted
certain ways while like the step
and fetch it mentality of like how
people viewed african americans was a
part of how african americans were drawn
in comics you didn't drop the n-bomb
in a comic book that's just not
something that you did and when chris
claremont did this it was a gamble it
was a very very
very dangerous game but it's not
designed for the purpose of just
throwing it out there and just saying
yep
n-bomb it's not designed to say that
instead what it's designed to do is show
the reality of the situation that the
x-men live in a persecuted group it's a
very significant moment in this story i
don't know if i can really
emphasize how important it is but it's
one of those things because when when
kitty pride runs off the response of
colossus is look stevie you can't take
it too personal she's upset here you
know she didn't mean what she said and
the response to stevie is
actually she did she really did like she
really meant that because it's true you
know it's an abs
it is a definitive statement would
stevie have felt the same way
if a different phrase had been thrown
out instead of mudy lover it was the end
bomb lover and so it's it's a it's a
very
interesting thing because it was kind of
chris claremont's critique of people
that like well
so long as they're not insulting my
group then i don't really care what it
is that they say you know it's it's a
it's a
striking statement to make but of course
while this is all going on it's all
being observed by by purifiers now the
initial response of the pure
response to the purifiers is they're
pretty extreme because one of them is
just like well i mean she's a beauty
lover kill her
like i mean we should just get rid of
her anybody who is a mutant or anybody
who sympathizes with him
needs to be taken out you know they're
they're evil they're bad we have to get
rid of them and so that's when you start
going into the debate that takes place
between charles xavier and william
striker and the debate is cut
short relatively fast in the sense that
as they're going through and debating
it's clearly one-sided and there's a lot
of things that hit in on this for
example when william striker is talking
to charles xavier he quotes a statement
that came from senator robert kelly's
committee on mutant affairs now for
those of you guys who don't know what
that is this takes place during the
events of project wide awake when the
sitting president at the time was
running for re-election
senator robert kelly was staunchly
anti-mutant and basically pushed the
hand of the president by running on the
campaign of saying well i'm against
mutants and so like mutants are credible
and they're a dangerous threat senator
robert kelly used that and ran on that
campaign platform which meant the
president had to do it as well
and so the president in turn launched
project wide awake the nsa the fbi the
cia
various state and local police
departments sheriff's departments so on
and so forth all basically finding a way
to categorize quantify
and to control the mutant threat that's
what the whole thing was this committee
on mutant affairs was part of senator
robert kelly's campaign
and so that was the whole idea was to
find a way to control mutants and when
this report came out this report was
mutants are legitimately dangerous they
are people with extraordinary powers
some of whom cannot control the powers
they have
and because they can't control them they
are in and of themselves a credible
threat for those who can control them
how do we keep them from killing all of
us that makes them a credible threat and
for the ones who seek to use their
powers for good
there's simply not enough of them to
keep the ones who will use them for evil
in check so we can't trust them to
police themselves and so again it was it
was kind of building this wall kind of
building it building you know building
this wall that set the x-men and set
mutants in brick by brick by brick to
kind of isolate them and to keep them
segregated and say they're inherently
bad guys and so it's kind of crazy here
because you have like people behind the
scenes you know like the guys in the in
the like the rooms who are watching
everything unfold the people who are
working at the news station
and their stance is yeah but with all
this stuff that william striker's saying
it's absolutely terrifying here but
with william strucker saying things like
well mutants are a credible threat
mutants are dangerous you know mutants
are people who need to be eliminated
because you know they are dangerous to
the rest of american society it's very
much mccarthyism it's very much world
war
ii era germany this is a group of people
who are bad and i have deemed them to be
bad and we say they're bad for arbitrary
standards
therefore we must contain and control
them if not just outright eliminate them
it's calling for the deaths of millions
of people and it's a terrifying scenario
because where people look at that where
you have like members of the news who
are looking at this you have the x-men
looking at this and even when the whole
debate is done and charles xavier wasn't
able to make all his points when he
talks to cyclops and says i think that
went poorly cyclops response is
absolutely because you played the
people's reason you played the people's
logic
but william striker played to their
fears and if anything
fear is one of the most powerful
emotions ever when people are afraid
they will do whatever they need to do
they'll believe whatever they want to
believe in order to make that fear go
away and so if william striker's sitting
on television and he's saying well
mutants are scary man
a mutant could be your child or your
child or maybe your child goes to school
with a mutant and then they do something
and just
wipe out all the kids in the classroom
it's fear-mongering and because people
are so easily terrified they buy into it
and where charles
ever tries to talk reason to it it
doesn't work it does not work because
charles xavier looks imposing charles
xavier looks
scary and because of that william
striker played on that and ultimately
won the perceptions of people and so in
response to this the x-men are kind of
like okay look we don't want to have
anything to do with this right now we're
all going to go work out and so for the
next little while the x-men are just
working out in the danger room literally
just going through and it's really kind
of
chris claremont showcasing their powers
and what they can do and what their
strength
strengths and weaknesses are and so on
and so forth and that while all that's
going on
the purifiers launched their campaign
they launched their ambush
on charles xavier and storm and cyclops
and this is one of
the important things to bear in mind
when it comes to the purifiers they're
well organized they're not just like a
bunch of crazy guys
like not a bunch of like crazy hicks or
like hobos or you know
nonsensical people with ridiculous
beliefs who are just running around with
guns like herder
mutant inspired like that's not that's
not what they are like they're very
they're very structured they're very
organized but more so than that the
purifiers are anybody the purifiers are
like bank accountants
businessmen and business women
politicians they're designed to be a
stand-in for the clan they could be
anyone
in your town you could walk by a
purifier and never know that's what
makes them so dangerous because they're
so well organized
so well hidden and when they launch
their attack against professor xavier
and cyclops and storm it is with
dangerous precision they shoot as they
need to they take them out as they need
to it's
fast and swift i mean it happens in the
blink of an eye and so from there you
end up having you know the x-men who are
kind of
you know recouping from their workout
and so on and so forth and you know the
phone rings nightcrawler picks it up and
nightcrawler basically gets the call
and saying that professor xavier and
cyclops and storm
have all been killed with that being
said guys we're going to bring this
video to an end
if you guys are new here to comments
explain make sure you guys hit the sub
button to become part of the rob corp if
you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and i will
catch you all later
peace
you